la noche del jueves fue la última para
muchos españoles que quisieron tomar una
última copa o cenar al aire libre en
cataluña los bares y restaurantes
estarán cerrados durante al menos dos
semanas un nuevo golpe para el sector
que ya había pagado un alto precio
durante el confinamiento antes de la
llegada del verano ya no podemos
aguantar hemos hemos gastado hasta los
ahorros nosotros si tenemos que cerrar
cerraremos pero también se tendría que
cerrar los colegios y tendrían que ser
aros del metro se tendría que
que volver un poco a una estado de
alarma porque las situaciones graves no
sólo para nosotros las entregas y la
comida para llevar todavía están
autorizadas para los restaurantes los
casinos también han cerrado y los
teatros solo pueden ocupar el 50 por
ciento de su capacidad todas estas han
sido decisiones tomadas por las
autoridades para intentar frenar la
propagación del virus en la región el
número de casos detectados a diario ha
superado la marca de los 2000 entre
agosto y septiembre se había registrado
en mil casos diarios las autoridades
regionales pidiendo a los residentes que
limiten los viajes y han anunciado 40
millones de euros en ayudas a bares y
restaurantes